[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean come in young tonight
ladies and gentlemen come in please we
need to start soon
yes it is life
[Music]
you
please take your seats
volunteers I think you can start closing
the doors you can reopen them for anyone
later on we'll be starting welcome
ladies and gentlemen this is three
speeds under attack I want to mention
that after the event both Fleming Rose
and Steve Simpson will be happy to sign
their books if you have them with them
and we are also selling extra copies
outside I am inviting the executive
chairman of the ion Institute your own
Brook to introduce the panelists welcome
everyone and welcome everyone a live
stream thank thank you I know and you
know I'm really I'm really thrilled to
to that we have this panel here today
I'm thrilled to be have the opportunity
to introduce this panel and I want to
put it a little bit in the context of of
Aoi and
AOS focus on this issue of free speech
which really goes back to 1989 with the
Salomon Rushdie affair which the
Institute and many objectives
intellectuals took a pretty firm stand
at the time on this issue and has since
become more and more and more of an
issue
unfortunately it's sad that this is
something we have to focus on and we've
really got to the point where this is
one of our key areas of focus so of all
the issues out there I can't think of an
issue more important than the issue of
free speech if you're seeing in the
panel I'm sure we'll discuss all this
what's going on campuses what's going on
politically there is no issue more
important when we are silenced there is
no more fight for a better world for a
better culture our only way to win this
is by the use of reason and therefore by
the use of speech when speech is gone
the battle is over if for all intensive
purposes I'm a this is a what you see
Knight is is in a sense something that
we are doing on campuses all over the
United States these days and as part of
our focus on free speech we are we are
we have a traveling traveling set of
panels we've already done full is
everybody this this year I think six six
this year and actually Fleming I did one
in Copenhagen and in December so seven
in recent times we've already got four
planned for the fall at various
universities and as long as this is a
major issue I think that we will be out
there in the public primary at
universities of fighting this fight now
I'm going to say just a few words on
each one of the panelists I'm not going
to read a formal bio the formal BIOS I
know in your packet so so you can read
them there but but Steve is as a
resident fellow Italian Institute and is
responsible really for everything we do
in terms of free speech he's working on
a book and free speech and is doing most
if not all of our panels on free speech
around the country as a former Institute
for justice lawyer and we're very very
happy to have Steve on our team at the
Institute Fleming and I go back 11 years
to the publication of the Danish
cartoons Fleming of course was
responsible for the publication of those
cartoons in 2005 and when all hell broke
out in 2006 some of you might remember
the Institute did a series of events at
universities where we blew up the
cartoons and and in traveled around the
country with these big Muhammad cartoons
and presented panels like this on free
speech and I got to know Fleming then he
participated a number of those panels
and and I'm
I'm proud to say that he's become a good
friend a personal friend and a friend of
the Institute we've done many many
events over the years together and and
we anticipate we will be cooperating on
a variety of different projects in in
the future Dave Rubin is a new friend I
did I did I first met him when I
interviewed Dave about just over a year
ago and if you haven't watched that
interview shame on you but you should
it's not it's not it's on YouTube and
it's a really really good interview and
I really think Dave is probably the best
interviewer of his generation and for
those of you who are not subscribed to
the Dave Rubin show on YouTube you
should not just for my interview but
really all the interviews Dave does has
done a fascinating interesting and he
has a real ability as I think you'll see
somewhat tonight
but even more so I think on YouTube a
real ability to draw people out and get
to the heart of issues with them so so I
think we've got a fantastic panel I
think this can be exciting night and
prepare questions we can have an
extensive Q&A afterwards and with that
I'm going to turn it over to Dave to
take it away
all right well give it up for your own
everybody
first off I really have to remember to
have someone else do the intros for my
show for now on because that that that's
the heavy lifting part now we're just
going to talk for an hour we are
streaming this this is the first ever
live Reuben report on location anywhere
thank you so this is being streamed to
my channel right now and you guys know
we've got a lot of classical liberals
over there also there's nothing like the
live YouTube chat that's happening right
now can you guys make some noise show
those trolls sure show the trolls that
Objectivists are not to be messed with
little wilder than expected we're
getting a standing ovation we would even
do anything yet that isn't impressive
all right I'm very excited to be here oh
and I just wanted to mention on a
personal note you wrote just mention
that he did my show a little over a year
ago he was actually I know for sure it
was a year in two weeks ago and actually
today June 13th is the one-year
anniversary of of us taking the Rubin
Report independent and one of the
reasons we did it was because of my
conversation with your own so if you
have seen it and if you have seen it or
if you haven't seen it you can actually
watch my thinking change because he was
talking about rational self-interest and
he was talking about individuality and
he was talking about getting rid of
regulations and I was at a nice Network
and we had health insurance and you know
all of those good things and and we had
snack room and the whole thing and and I
listened to your own talking about these
ideas and of course I'd been familiar
with them but once I had that
conversation with him it truly changed
the trajectory of my life and two weeks
later we launched when independent and
and now I think we're doing okay so
where's your own one more time I want to
thank him oh he's right there okay
[Music]
all right
first up we're going to need some more
of that screaming and hooting in honor
and while we're doing this all right
that's good too okay here we go we're
going to talk about free speech if you
do watch my show I truly believe that
the battle for free speech is the single
most important issue of our time when I
when I sat down with your own and Jim
and some of them Steve and some of the
other guys we very quickly agreed that
we don't have to agree on everything
politically but if we can agree on free
speech the absolute defense of free
speech that we can go ahead and do a
tour that we've started doing and then
we're going to continue in the fall and
and I really believe from everything
we're fighting on college campuses to
what's happening in the media to fake
news to things related to Trump that
this is the issue of our time I think
many of you probably agree with me on
that so let's let's start the
conversation let's just do something
just kind of simple first which is when
we've talked about the battle for free
speech there's two things happen here
there's sort of the chilling effect
that's happening where people are
silencing themselves and then there's
the government coming for free speech
now I'm focused on the first one of
those generally because I see that as a
bigger threat right now which do you see
is a bigger threat in the current scheme
of what's happening that we're doing it
to ourselves these words of racist
bigoted homophobic ofoh but that is
silenced has or you fear the government
I think self-censorship right now and
chilling ourselves is the bigger issue
and the way I would put it is that you
can you can think of the attacks on free
speech can come from I mean strictly
speaking as a right it comes from
government right the attacks on and this
is the first amendment is a protection
against the government right but but you
can also destroy your own free speech
intellectually and/or your own right to
free speech and support for free speech
so we have to think about free speech
it's a right obviously an individual
right against government we have the
right to say whatever we want so long as
we don't write violate the right rights
of others and we can talk about what
that means exactly but we also have to
treat it as a
you and your on mentioned the it's it's
really a fight for the supremacy of
reason the supremacy of the individual
thinking for yourself and and there's a
philosophical context in that supports
that you can think of it really simply
and and we'll elaborate on this as the
enlightenment worldview the individual
the individual mind you know we are we
have to chart our course in life we have
to think for ourselves and part of
thinking of ourselves and charting our
own course is speaking our own minds
it's a tremendous value I mean it we
could not have the modern world without
it and today you see a real assault on
that and and it's coming from I think
primarily it's a philosophical
intellectual assault and a lot of things
you talked about and that we all no
doubt talked about because there's
examples of this all over the place
today on college campuses and elsewhere
are really undermining the right I think
people are willingly giving it up they
are and we've seen people apologize for
their for for speaking out so that's the
primary fit but there are also
government threats to that we we can
talk about but so funny but yeah Steve
mentioned logic and reason you put
Mohammed cartoons in a publication yes
were you using logic and reason when you
do that absolutely but what also
instinct and in fact that journalistic
project was also provoked by what I saw
as growing self-censorship among
intellectuals writers painters
illustrators and so on and so forth and
and the reason why self-censorship is so
difficult to handle is that it is
invisible and it's not very courageous
to censor yourself and therefore most
people will lie when they commit
self-censorship
they will come up with all kinds of good
reasons for not saying something that
sounds rational even though in a lot of
cases
you will suppose that they are driven by
fear and and the the trigger thing about
self-censorship
which I define as in in the following
way you you you want to say something
but you you refrain from saying it
because you are afraid of what might
happen to you you cannot pass a law
against fear you cannot protect people
against fear and and and that is a
crucial difference between censorship
and self-censorship censorship define
clear red lines self-censorship do not
do not imply clear red lines but you
internalize an atmosphere or a sense of
what you cannot say and and it's it's
very difficult to find
I'm curious I'll kind of throw this to
the audience I mean it's partly that we
live in a diverse society I look out
here I see do I see the diversity that
the left loves and that I see white
people and I see black people and I see
Asian people and all sorts and gay
people as great people but what I care
about is diversity of thought that has
always struck me as more important than
the immutable characteristics that any
of us have so just to see diversity of
thought by show hands how many Nazis do
we have here
just a simple salute would be fine Nazis
no no not so he did a half thing okay
cool talk to you later
no Nazis here but but that concept of
diversity it's making people not want to
offend anyone and that chill factor I
mean I get emails every day people say
Dave I I don't want to post your video
with Flemming on on Facebook because I
don't want someone to defend against ort
of state-sponsored censorship but we're
slowly eroding something that's very
important yeah individualism is the way
I would put it and so I mean if you
think about you you've got to be clear
about what diversity means diversity of
thought diversity of ideas I mean it's
definitely has its it's a very important
thing in many different contexts and
certainly on college campuses and in
other areas the way I would put Altima
the way I think about free speech and
freedom of thought is it's the pursuit
of truth in the pursuit of knowledge
now diversity of thought helps you along
the way so debating confront confronting
ideas that are contrary to yours I mean
I don't think you can learn without
doing that and that in that sense
diversity of thought is hugely important
and in any event we all have the freedom
in a free society to say what we want to
engage with others etc diversity the way
it's used in you know in in common
parlance today I think it's it's
diversity of and then you can fill in
the blank but it's the way I would
characterize its diversity of all sorts
of non essential characteristics I had
nothing to do with individual thought it
has to do with things like race gender
etc so I mean I always think of this
issue as in terms of Martin Luther
King's statement that you judge a man
based on the content of his character
not the color of his skin and then by
extension nor all sorts of other
non-essential characteristics so but
when you talk about diversity it's a
very collectivist group based a concept
which is typically about gender it's
about sex it's about race which once you
do that you're forming people into
tribes and then you have to have a kind
of thought police on them and I think
that's what we're that's what we're
seeing but but there also is a paradox
here because the people who tends to
celebrate diversity of culture ethnicity
and religion they do not celebrate
diversity of speech and I've always been
of the opinion that if you if you
welcome diversity of culture ethnicity
and religion it goes with the territory
that you will have had to accept that if
people are different
they will also express themselves in
more different and diverse ways and the
irony right now in Europe where I spend
most of my time is that that
the majority of European politicians
they want to manage this growing
diversity of culture ethnicity and
religion by limiting diversity of speech
in order to keep the social peace and
that's why in fact Western Europe for
the past few years have passed laws that
are very similar to laws that are being
passed in countries that we usually
don't compare ourselves will fit I mean
to Germany right now is about to pass a
law criminalizing fake news and as
someone who spent time in a dictatorship
in the Soviet Union where the true for
sanctioned by the government it just
runs down my spine when I hear that the
government is to determine what is fake
news and what isn't and they they it's
it's a way of of trying to to manage
this this growing diversity and it's
straight long I think is there any
evidence throughout history that either
one of you can think of where that you
know silencing or stopping an idea from
being heard has actually worked that
that's the psychological reason I would
like to use on the people that are
trying to sound things there any
evidence of them even in the Soviet
Union which was hard to Territorian
dictatorship they didn't succeed and and
I would I would say quite to the
contrary you you you you don't kill an
idea by banning it you kill an idea or
you did legitimize an idea by allowing
people to speak their mind and then take
it apart Holocaust denial for instance I
think 13 countries in Europe right now
have laws criminalizing Holocaust denial
in a situation where Europe is
experiencing mass immigration from the
Muslim world where you have a lot of
Holocaust deniers so so these people
they come to Europe they have been
taught that it was all
invented by the Jews and they are not
being allowed to express these
outrageous opinions and it means that we
are not just not able to educate them
and fight them and they will just come
to the conclusion that the Jews they are
ruling Europe in the same way they wrote
in the Middle East some kind
it's just reinforcing their conspiracy
theories and that's that said and and
and once you go down that road people
will come up with all other kinds of
memory laws establishing certain
versions of history as the truth in in
Eastern Europe
I think it's 9 countries who have passed
laws criminalizing denial of the crimes
of communism Russia passed a law in 2014
criminalizing criticism of the behavior
of the Soviet Union during the second
world war we have reference to the
Holocaust denial laws in Western Europe
they just said you know this is very
sensitive to us Holocaust denial may be
very sensitive to you but this is
sensitive to us and therefore we pass
these kind of laws yeah Stephen I
actually had a pretty amazing moment on
our tour we were at the University of
Arizona and I did that that joke that I
did with you guys a couple minutes ago
about diversity and I asked for a Nazi
and literally someone in the back of the
room stood up and said I'm a Nazi and
the crowd kind of groaned a little bit
and and then it was it was a woman and
she started talking about that she
didn't believe
outch wits had a door that would lock or
something kind of nutty and we were with
Michael Shermer Michael's been on my
show a few times some of you guys
probably know Michael he he runs skeptic
magazine and he debunks these conspiracy
theories so he could tell that she had a
conspiracy theory waiting and I thought
well this is a good teachable moment so
I said to her look let us finish the
speech and the panel and then at the end
when we do the QA we'll give you the
first question and that's what we did
and her first question she
asked about some very convoluted
confusing question about about the gas
chambers and Michael fully debunked her
said he had been there he knew exactly
what she was talking about laid it out
with facts and logic and reason now of
course I'm sure that did not you know
change her opinion in any way but it got
everyone else there to see that we were
putting our money where our mouth is and
we were using free speech and allowing
someone else to use theirs the
interesting part of this it turned out
the woman was also trans which how many
of you know trans Holocaust deniers I
thought I thought that was a real niche
thing that we were Hiller was all about
the trans people if I'm not mistaken
right yeah but it was a great teachable
moment yeah letting someone speak even
if you don't like their ideas and then
letting logic and reason dictate the
answer yeah definitely and and that's
absolutely essential to have a free
society it's absolutely essential to
allow people the freedom to reach their
own conclusions true or not but the way
you ask the question I think was
interesting it's have they ever worked
have hate speech laws or restricting
thought or speech ever work and my aunt
might answer that is well it really
depends on what you mean by worked so in
one sense yeah they have work they've
worked to enslave entire societies I
mean we look at it totalitarianism they
control thought because they need to
control action and they need to control
what everybody does so the first thing
they do is censor the first thing they
do is control what people can think now
if you look at it from the standpoint of
a free society what we have now both in
America and Europe is a very much a
mixture of freedom and controls but you
can't ever succeed in that way you
cannot succeed to keep bad ideas down by
outlawing them in fact all you end up
doing is you draw you drive them beneath
the surface and then you you cause the
very hate and resentment that you're
trying to prevent and the reason for
that is you can't force people to think
it's just not possible you can enslave
them but you cannot force them to agree
with you yeah so let's talk a little bit
about the slippery slope of all this
that I think you guys are probably aware
of if you look on Twitter these days
everybody's all about punching Nazis
like people think that they're Indiana
Jones and they
out there bunch of Nazis you guys can
laugh louder if you want if you're
feeling it I can sense a little
hesitation
remember that energy at the beginning so
Richard Spencer who's you know this this
suppose all right leader I guess he
likes frogs it's a little unclear to me
what what the deal is with this guy but
on Inauguration Day I'm sure many of you
saw this some random person punched him
and and just a ton of people I saw a ton
of seemingly good sensible people saying
yes it is okay to punch Nazis and I was
in the you know the unenviable position
of having to defend this person whose
ideas I find abhorrent I had family
members die on both sides of my family
in the Holocaust like these are horrific
ideas but I had to defend him that
slippery slope thing I mean you you've
been through some of this yeah and I was
I mean I was accused of of being also a
nots in facts but I didn't reply to your
question when you asked if there are any
Nazis out there but no people people
said to me you know you should be
careful publishing these kind of
cartoons because we know what happened
in the 20s and furthers and and it comes
down to an understanding of the
relationship between words and deeds
that basically is no difference that
words are violence and therefore you can
be violent or you can use words but but
to me that is exactly the dividing line
between civilization and Barberie
and and if if you go back into history I
think the the most crucial moment in the
fight for freedom of expression was when
after the Wars of Religion in Europe
when Protestant and Catholics had killed
one another for decades in the tens of
thousand societies decided to establish
a clear distinction between words and
deeds that attacks on Christianity on
verbal attacks were not being perceived
anymore as physical attacks and you
didn't put people on the stake for
saying blasphemies or heretical things
and and and and establishing that
dividing line is is crucial to
civilization to democracy to freedom of
expression and unfortunately today in
fact we are moving back into the Middle
Ages in the sense that we are eroding
this this distinction between words and
deeds and therefore people people can
say it's okay to punch a Nazi and they
can also say that if you publish
cartoons of the Prophet Muhammad it's
like killing somebody and and it it it
it it leads it's the road into a very
dark place if you follow that logic is
the biggest issue with that logic that
the definition of a Nazi or whatever
label you want to use will always expand
so if one person says it's okay it's
okay to punch your Nazi it's okay to
punch Richard Spencer well someone else
will mate well okay well if we can punch
him can we can we blow up his house I
mean what if his wife and kids are in
there can we what if it's not a Nazi but
it's someone with equally abhorrent
who's like we're it's just a train that
you can't stop that's definitely part of
I mean one of the things that I've been
debating with people on Twitter and
Facebook is well okay you want to punch
the Nazis I guess we also should punch
communists right and then socialists too
because look what's happening in
Venezuela I mean they're killing each
other that's horrible so somebody go
punched Bernie Sanders after that it's
if you want to look back to the Middle
Ages look at the Christian
did we got to start punching Christians
you know Muslims are killing people in
foreign countries them to punch list you
know and pretty soon the list is like
it's an endless list of everybody in
history and and I mean so yet definitely
this idea that that we go after people
for their ideas is abhorrent even if
their ideas are abhorrent and but we
have to understand there's a way to
define the line that Fleming was talking
about and I mean this is a you know
vastly oversimplified but the the the
line is individual rights and we have to
make a distinction between the use of
force either to threaten or to or the
initiation of force to threaten others
or threatening or actually using it
against others versus the use of ideas
so if a Richard Spencer he can spout all
of his nonsense as much as he wants what
he can't do is put those ideas into
practice because yes those ideas do lead
to violence if you really take them
seriously and you follow them he cannot
go around and start attacking people or
threatening people or banding together
with other Nazis and saying we're going
to take over the country that is all
illegal and thankfully in free countries
we already have systems of laws that
deal with that I mean the criminal law
does a really good job of that but but
as Fleming pointed out we've we've
gotten to a point now where I think in
part we don't know where that line is
but also there are whole philosophies
that hold that in effect ideas are
really threatening and part of the
reason for that I always put it as look
if you want to defend the indefensible
if your ideas are stupid if they're
crazy of course you're going to be
threatened by other ideas and I mean
that's where we see with with with Islam
and with a lot of the other ideas but I
think you know a lot of the people who
are attacking Richard Spencer they have
a reason to fear this because their own
ideas are crazy and they don't know how
to defend ideas so they're going to go
after him with force instead of
persuasion yeah do you think that guys
like us who do this for a living that
even we have certain limits I was
thinking that just last week I did my
direct message about Bill Maher and you
know I'm sure you guys saw Bill Maher he
said that he said the n-word now I have
to say even describe it I can't even
quote him right now because it I have to
say the n-word because if I was even to
quote in which is what I addressed in my
in my video that even that would somehow
be perceived that I was racist so in a
weird way we we all accept certain
limitations on our speech even though I
give Bill Maher a hundred percent
full-throated defense of what he was
making a joke you could say it was a bad
joke or whatever but the idea that he
was making some sort of racist comment
is completely crazy he subsequently he's
done an apology so we all sort of have
these they even for those about that are
putting ourselves out and and that's
fine
I mean you decide for yourself what kind
of limits you want to impose on yourself
but that's something you do voluntarily
I think the problem arises when you
would like to impose your limits on
others I mean I like when people speak
nice to me I try to speak nice to people
myself but I'm not trying to impose my
standards of civility on another's and I
think I think that's that's what
unfortunately a lot of people they are
doing they are trying to impose their
standards on everybody even though we
belong to different social political
cultural religious groups where we have
different social norms and I there is a
very good American constitutional
scholar his name is robert post and he
makes the point that in fact all hate
speech laws they are not passed in order
to fight hate they are passed in order
to enforce the a certain social norm and
and you know that's easier when
everybody are the same when when
everybody believes in the same God when
they more or less follow the same rules
but as society's growing more and more
diverse if you
then then then in fact it becomes very
undemocratic in the sense that you are
trying to impose one social norm on
everybody
even though different groups may
subscribe to different social norms but
I I think basically I mean we shouldn't
kid ourselves so there is a reason why
free speech is in bad standing it is
because it is very fragile and and for
for the vast majority of history mankind
didn't enjoy free speech because the
instinct for most human beings is to
shut down opinions and speech that they
don't like it's just not it's just in a
way it takes education it takes reason
it takes the ability to to to not react
instinctively and and that's not easy
it's it's it's very very difficult so
and that's also why it's lived through
what you've lived through I think people
probably view you as that you're somehow
supernaturally brave you know like we've
discussed this on my show but you when
you did this ten years ago or so eleven
years ago you were in pinning your this
wasn't something that you even cared
about that much you just felt that you
were going to do this but now you're
viewed as someone that's incredibly
brave and then we have all sorts of
other people out there that are afraid
to post things but you really just view
yourself as just a person that's picking
this battle right yeah I mean you do you
don't pick your own battles in life some
sometimes they're being imposed upon you
and I didn't ask for this fight in fact
because I I didn't think that publishing
you know those cartoons would trigger
the kind of reactions we received but
that's when what you believe in is being
tested and I think I mean I was very
surprised that I didn't have more
support around the Western world because
I believed that
speech is a fundamental value and I I i
understood along the way that because i
had spent time in the Soviet Union
because I had worked at the Danish
Refugee Council with dissidents from the
former Soviet Union I had a different
approach to these issues they really
meant something to me and I would say
you know from for me it was not a it was
it was not a question about you know
personal bravery on my part because I
didn't think about it in those terms it
was more about you know I have some
individuals behind the Iron Curtain whom
I perceive as my personal heroes Andrei
Sakharov vaslov Havel Solzhenitsyn natan
Sharansky people who really went to
labor camps for what they believed in
and and having them as heroes
I could not you know I could not look at
myself in the mirror betraying their
ideals so in a way it was very natural
it was and I I didn't think about the
fritz in the beginning I was more
thinking about you know what are my
arguments what the what I mean what my
worst nightmare was if somebody was able
to confront me with something that I
hadn't thought about and really pointing
to a weak spot in my argumentation that
was really my nightmare
may sound crazy but but that's the way
it was
it seems actually like it makes perfect
sense because we see this de platforming
at college campuses and burning down
Berkeley when when Milo shows up and
even some of the things that we've had
to do where we've had to have extra
security this I like what you said there
because you were trying to strengthen
your own ideas so that you would be able
to have that in to intellectual
challenge is that the biggest problem of
what's happening on the college campuses
right now that these kids I mean we can
make all the jokes about safe spaces and
trigger warnings and all that stuff but
that they actually are stopping people
from challenging their thoughts at the
very place where that is exactly what
it's supposed to be yeah absolutely
that's a big big problem but but the way
I would put it is they don't want to
pursue truth they don't want so I mean
one of the ways I would summarize what
you just said is you were holding truth
as your standard and and I mean you're I
would call it virtue as well and and and
you were pursuing the truth and so you
were more concerned that you made a
mistake rather than that a lot of people
were criticizing you and which is
exactly the right mentality you should
have on pursuing truth I'm trying to
figure out the way to live my life from
trying to figure out how to go through
life and pursue my own happiness but
that's not the standard anymore and it's
part of the reason that what you have to
ask yourself why did so many people
criticize what Fleming did he he he
criticized an ideology implicitly I mean
you can you can talk about whether I'm
stating this the right way but the way I
would put it is criticized a medieval
ideology a crazy ideology in likely a
totally false ideology and by doing what
publishing some cartoons of the Prophet
Muhammad and people went berserk that
that is so we should criticize
ideologies like that we should judge
people's ideas that's an important part
so you said we all have limits to our
free speech I wouldn't quite put it that
way I would put it as we all have to
understand the world and I think we
pursue truth in our own lives but we
should be prepared to judge ideas it's
not so this is where the idea of
diversity of thought and diversity of
opinion kind of breaks down because if I
hear Roberts spent oh sorry Richard
Spencer speaking on the street I want
to size the hell out of him and say look
this is evil what you stand for is evil
and we cannot abide by that we should
also say the same thing about you know
radical Islam or totalitarian Islam and
I think Christianity and all kinds of
other crazy ideas but the bottom line is
people have to be willing not crazy
ideas yeah and that's crazy ideas to
challenge our own ideas but the standard
ultimately has to be that we are willing
to judge ideas because ideas can be good
or bad if we take enough if we take a
non-judgmental position toward the
goodness or badness the good or evil of
ideas then we we essentially it's a
moral agnosticism and that's what allows
bad ideas to thrive that's why when you
get to a point of of decades of doing
this there's a there's a reason I think
there's a kind of legitimacy in thinking
well if we're not going to judge any
ideas if we're not going to go after
these guys and criticize them maybe
their ideas will take off maybe people
will end up believing these crazy things
is there nothing we can do no you can
criticize them you can't attack them but
criticize them we have confidence in the
fact that the truth will ultimately
prevail if you're a reasonable rational
person but I mean there's a whole I
think philosophical context to that but
I guess that my last comment will be we
have to have confidence in reason and
the ability of individuals to arrive at
the truth so
yeah there's a lot agree of coming back
to your starting point about where where
does the phrase from speech free speech
come from you you you said used to be
from the government and maybe it's not
from the government anymore but I you
could phrase it in a different way it
used to come from all kinds and
fundamentalism enforced by the
government but not only by the
government also by the church or by
ideological movements and so on and so
forth that in fact believed that they
were in possession of the truth and the
N and if you challenge the truth
I remember Ayatollah Khomeini who was
interviewed by Oriana Fallaci after the
Islamic Revolution in Iran he basically
said you know as far as I remember I
never made a mistake great comment but
but what but but the and and I think
fundamentalism is pretty easy to figure
out because people really I mean
challenge you when they they don't want
you to say anything the the threat today
comes from good people or the
humanitarian argument that there are
certain things that you should not say
if you want to stay a good person and if
you say it you're a bad person and and
and that's that's far more difficult to
challenge compared to fundamentalism
that is you know straight out censorship
this is also straight out censorship but
it's it's it's packaged in in you know
that we had to be nice we have to be
good and so on and so forth and I think
what you basically said I think it was
Jonathan Roush who formulated in a
brilliant way I think in his book kindly
inquisitors he basically said you know
that that that the liberal scientific
model is based on two principles that
there can be no final say that the
debate never stops you're always allowed
to challenge to ask critical questions
no matter what and there is no personal
Authority you cannot say because I'm
black or because I'm the Pope that I'm
entitled to the truth just because I am
the person I am and these two principles
are in fact mean like the foundation of
the Enlightenment and we have given up
on both and that's why we are where we
are now but I don't want to minimize
though just really quickly I don't want
to minimize like when I said before I
think the primary threat is coming from
in a sense ourselves and intellectual
threats to free speech I don't want to
minimize government government is always
a potential threat to free speech and
it's an actual threat both here and in
Europe I think is actually worse worse
than Europe because you guys have hate
speech laws which are a serious serious
threat to free speech but I mean if you
talk about college campuses we've
discussed the the impact of title nine
and the fact that and and you can think
about anti-discrimination laws
I mean campaign finance laws are a
threat there are all kinds of
governmental threat most aute both overt
that are easy to see and then more sort
of covert I mean the very existence of
public universities I see is a threat to
freedom of speech because we're
financing people's ideas and then the
question is whose ideas do you finance
and then you have a scramble for more
government money and that kind of crowds
out the truth sort of gets crowded out
that way
where people stop caring about the truth
one way or another and they just are
fighting for for funds so I don't want
to minimize government the way I would
put is the primary threat to free speech
as with any other right is the
initiation of force by you know
criminals governments the Pope organized
religion and then you know in the olden
days it was criminal gangs and and you
know the kings and the Pope's in these
days it's modern governments or if we
end up allowing what's happening on
college campuses now which is
essentially you know criminal gangs of
students that's what the way I would put
it roving gangs of students who attacked
other people for speaking out that if
you ruin the rule of law you will not
have free speech anymore so we have to
be really clear about the real threat is
you know using force against people and
whether that comes from government or
private people is the inherent problem
here that there's there's no end
here this movement sort of can't end if
you were to look at what's happening
right now at Evergreen State College I'm
sure many of you guys are familiar with
this with professor Brent Weinstein who
I had on my show he quite literally was
opposing a day where they were gonna
tell white students not to come to
campus so he was genuinely opposing
racism but that didn't stop the the
bigoted ear brigade from from jumping
out and now the campus has been closed
for a couple days over the last few
weeks he hasn't been back on the campus
he's not getting a defense from the
administration does that show just how
structural the whole problem is we have
a problem with a student base that's
sort of running the asylum we have a
problem with with academics who aren't
stepping up and saying what's right we
have a problem with administrators who
have other pressures that it's really
it's many things at once yes many things
and and I had a very educating
experience earlier this year in
Lancaster I spoke at the Frank Franklin
Marshall College I was allowed to speak
in fact I spoke the same night that
charles murray was chased off stage in
Middlebury so that was a great success
but but I was met with the posters
outside the auditorium check your white
privilege at the door and I didn't
understand in fact in the beginning but
I was allowed to speak and there was a
silent protest throughout my speech and
then we had the Q&A and I tried to say
to them that you know we should not
focus so much on what our differences
are as human beings we share the same
themes in fact and we have far more in
common than divides us and they just
laughed and they laughed in a very
sinister and sarcastic way as if I was
engaged in some kind of cover-up
and to me that was very educating and
and it's really I think identity
politics is a key word here that that
basically they believed that we couldn't
have a conversation because I'm white
and they were black or I'm a non Muslim
and they were Muslims and we have so
different experiences that we are just
not able to share the same universe
while in fact we know from art from
marriages from our traveling that every
human being has the capacity to put
himself in another person's shoes write
about it talk about it played onstage or
whatever it is and I think I think you
know this pitching holding everybody
into these boxes of religion or
ethnicity and culture is very very bad
ironically that is actual prejudice that
it is judging based on these immutable
candy and it in it it reduces you just
to one part of who you are as a human
being I mean I'm I'm a husband I'm a
father I'm a grandfather I'm probably an
atheist I'm an expert on Russia
I'm a senior fellow at Cato I am a
Tottenham Hotspurs soccer fan I mean I'm
all kinds of things and I just don't
want my identity to be reduced to just
one aspect and and that's what all these
things are doing and that's also the way
you can control people and and tell them
what to think and what to believe and so
on and so forth
are you saying that we shouldn't
apologize everyone for being white
because there are three white guys up
here you guys want to boo us or tomatoes
or say sorry
so one point here what what it reduces
us to as members of a larger group so
this is a and what we're talking about
here we are we are seeing the
consequences of a long you know many
many decades even centuries of very bad
philosophy and there are a number of
there's a lot that one can say about it
part of it is collectivism its and and I
think the best way to describe it in
today's world its tribalism it's it's
you are a member of a tribe and you are
you should say only what that tribe says
and I mean if you look at the way tribes
function they always rigidly enforce you
know tribal adherence and and because
the whole idea is there is no such thing
as the individual there's only a member
of a group and your role as an
individual is just to give yourself over
and sacrifice your life to the for the
good of the group there's another
element of this which is and I raised
this before it's an attack on reason I
mean the multi-cultural is the identity
politics people the intersectionality
people the postmodernist which a lot of
what you're seeing on campus today they
deny the whole idea of an objective
reality that we can know and that we can
discuss and talk about if you if you
deny objective reality what is what is
left I mean what they say is is reality
is just a social construct and that
we're all effectively we're in effect
created by the dominant views and that
that you know the world consists of
oppressors and oppressed we're all just
part of groups you have to have
something to guide you in life and if
you're not going to be guided by your
own mind in your own individual thought
process you've got to be guided by
something and the whether they're guided
by now is either it's emotional it's
emotion or its adherence to some groups
so they don't really I think kids have
been totally philosophically and
intellectually disarmed they don't know
how to approach the world and if you
attack or criticize them they
immediately lash out at you because
they've been they've been intellectually
deprived it deprived of the ability to
think is this also a condemnation of
social media I mean we all sort of
pigeonhole ourselves and you know I try
to follow a wide variety of people so
that I'm
just getting information that's that's
confirming the things that I believe but
that we all sort of do this our Facebook
feeds start you know backing our own
opinions that we already have we get rid
of people that say other things that
we're all we're all part of the problem
here in our own way yeah and it goes
back to the beginning of our
conversation the difficulty of managing
diversity it also goes on and so on
social media you like and share things
that you like which means that you will
just get more on social media so it it
reinforces these bubbles and it's also
about diversity and our difficult is
living with diversity and and and to me
the the biggest threat in fact a free
speech today is the undermining of our
understanding of the concept of
tolerance because tolerance is key if
you want to be able to manage diversity
tolerance basically means that you are
willing to live with things that you
hate without banning them through the
law you don't try to shut them down
through intimidation threats of violence
that is basically what tolerance is and
but but unfortunately tolerance has been
turned on its head
so today tolerance means that you should
not offend anyone which is exactly
opposite of its original meaning because
it means that you had to live with
things that's offensive to you that you
don't like but I think that's part of
the problem with using the term
tolerance is it's a fuzzy idea to begin
with and but I get what you're saying
you're using it in the very Lockean
sense of toleration means not killing
people that you disagree whether or not
it's a way of May
or not in prison Disick rabbits and and
certainly I mean that's there's
definitely an element to that say I mean
you're you're living in a society you
have to be willing at times to walk away
from people maybe you want to learn from
them you sort of think about like I'm
going to give them the opportunity to
talk I want to really listen and learn
from them but we also have to keep in
mind that part of what we need to be
willing to do is judge other people
judge their ideas and argue with them to
say look I think this is true and that's
false and now what we need from
government is a government that
absolutely protects our right to do that
and and so both are I think our
conception of of what free speech means
is it's it's clouded I think that if we
if we reject the idea of judging other
people and criticizing but I mean truth
is the arbiter yeah that's that's what
about what I believe Steve that the
Torah that that it's part of the concept
of Tolerance that you judge and that you
speak out against things that you don't
like you just don't try to ban them and
you don't use violence and intimidation
to shut them down and and and to me
Charles are free and freedom are two
sides of the same coin in our world
today there is a tension between
tolerance and freedom as if they are
opposites and you somehow have to
balance them but but there can be no
freedom without tolerance which means
that you allow people with whom you
disagree to speak their mind and and
there can be no tolerance without
freedom that is that people had to right
the right to say things that others just
don't like probably it's both because I
know everyone's gonna want to get to the
Q&A let's shift a little bit to the
government because we haven't talked
about the government at all is there a
threat right now to free speech from the
government I don't see a glaring one at
the moment if I if I was to you know
click the hash tag resist on Twitter it
seems as
there there is a massive threat under
Trump I I haven't seen it now there's an
obvious tension between him and the
mainstream media we also have we just
have a pretty crappy mainstream media
we've got a ton of fake news
I see threats there and that people are
having trouble agreeing on what's true
so to apply logic and reason is becoming
more difficult if we can't agree on what
the basic facts are but in terms of the
government do you sense right now that
there's a unique threat or what level
would you say the fact I don't think
it's unique to the Trump heir although
there's one caveat to that that I'll get
to in a minute but I mean there's always
there's a greater threat from government
when our categories are fuzzy and we
don't understand what the proper purpose
of government is or what the scope and
of our freedom is and how to think about
that and and the key concept here is
individual rights and we just we've
practically banished the idea or a
coherent idea of what individual rights
are all about from our lexicon these
days and this has been a long time in
coming we've really diluted it or just
destroyed the the idea of it so it's
much more an issue of who has the
privilege to do you know it's not just
speak but it's do all kinds of things
and so we need to you know we need to
recapture the Enlightenment view but I
mean the founders are really the ones
that I think defined this at least
implemented in political terms but
because of that the government is always
sort of hovering around as a threat and
then when you get a guy like Trump in
office who seems like I mean he's crazy
I think he's a nut I just you know I
don't I think he's a nut ball and and
and he's he's a really kind of he's just
a dangerous person because he recognizes
no limits to the authority of government
but he hasn't done anything unique other
than I mean he criticizes the media I'm
not I think it's dangerous for a
president to be criticizing the press as
an institution in the same way that I
thought it was very bad for Obama to be
criticizing the financial industry or
Wall Street as an institution doesn't
mean there aren't bad actors in there
but when you dam an entire institution
that's that's a dangerous thing
especially from a government who has the
power to actually regulate them and shut
them down there are specific threats at
title 9 we mentioned let me mention one
other sort of threat that is I think
moat the most terrifying
happening in this country now is
inaction by government when individuals
or groups of individuals and I think
this is happening on campus primarily
when they start using force against
people and we forget that the
distinction between freedom and you know
totalitarianism or freedom and not
freedom is the use of force so you look
at Middlebury you look at Evergreen as
the two recent examples and in both
cases you have people getting attacked
by bands of students you have the just
you have students then justifying the
attacks as self-defense which is crazy
it's not self-defense it's offense and
then you have the administration telling
the police essentially to stand down and
we're not going to protect people if
people come to view free speech in those
terms or that's what they associate with
free speech no one will support the idea
of free speech if they think that that
that people have a right to attack
others and then we're going to look at
that as speech or protest
I wouldn't reject that the concept of
free speech if that were the case but
it's really scary to see you know
college officials telling the campus
police to stand down and do nothing
local officials doing nothing about it
and essentially that what you get then
is replacing force with persuasion and
you get that the the the the dominant
principle becomes the way we settle
disputes and the societies through force
that's anarchy I mean that's and then I
mean you've lost the ability to speak
you've lost the ability to deal with
people on rational terms and that's an
important step down the road to you know
to statism I mean I think you should
always be on the alert when it comes to
the government and and the cover the
government will always be a potential
threat to free speech and and I think in
the u.s. when it comes to the law when
it comes to the courts way of
interpreting the law there is no
immediate threat to
to free speech when it comes to the
First Amendment because this Supreme
Court right now is is deciding the way
it does but it's but it's it's it's not
a given as Steven I talked about before
we started that you only have to go back
50 years 60 years where there was a very
different interpretation of the First
Amendment and and that could happen
again
and if we talk about from I mean Trump
in fact called for enforcing libel laws
he didn't know that there is no federal
libel law so in state law so so he
doesn't have a change to to do it right
now but but if he had a majority in
Congress if he had five seats in the
Supreme Court he would be able to to do
it and and and I think I think I think
you know if you I think that the digital
technology in a strange way is also
putting pressure on on on freedom of the
press after New York Times versus
Sullivan I think it was 1964 it has been
up to the media to determine what is
relevant when it comes to protection of
privacy the media had a right to to
inform the public about about almost
everything but after Golka they were
convicted in fact for invasion of
privacy they they they broadcast that I
think a sex video of a Breslau and a
good friend's wife and they were taken
to court and they lost and they they
went into bankruptcy and and this was
possible because there was no you know
maybe faro editorial process like at the
New York Times but it means that the
courts are not willing anymore to to to
provide to the media the sovereign right
to determine what they what they what
what they have a right to
dish and that is new and we don't know
where this stops there will always be
people in government who would like to
use this to shutdown speech that they
don't like yeah I actually think Gawker
was probably the right outcome so maybe
you were yeah they thought with me no
I'm not I'm not I'm not judging the
decision I'm I'm just I'm just revealing
the principle because this could this
can be used in other cases in ways that
you would not support yeah
but part of the issue then or I think
the big issue is we have to figure out
correct and rational legal standards and
principles and that ultimately comes
from a coherent view of individual
rights why we have individual rights and
how you violate them I don't want to go
into all the details yeah I mean we can
talk more about it but I want to leave
this up to you but and maybe people will
question us about libel law is a hard
one but but I think Gawker was probably
rightly decided but that doesn't mean
it's not a threat and you're right that
Donald Trump again I said he was not you
know the idea that that he thinks
there's a federal law of libel easin
even seem to understand what any of this
means it's just I want to go after the
press that's crazy and it's dangerous
all right well on that crazy and
dangerous note I think we should kick
this to you guys so did these guys are
out of applause
[Music]
oh that was literally that was the
fastest - I've ever seen - a microphone
for today a pile oh yeah I mean I do
I've talked to a bunch of you guys over
the last couple days I know we've got
some bright people here but I sense I
sense we're gonna have our work cut out
for us all right so I try to keep them
relatively brief and we can do this for
an hour though and should we give them a
list of topics that are we have to talk
about or see what I did there
okay go ahead okay I want to thank you
three courageous men for all you've done
in the fight for free speech especially
Dave who inspired me
especially Dave who inspired me to get
off my ass and speak my mind online for
the first time so thanks for that my
question is I've been waiting for you
given the current climate at
universities like evergreen and the
violence committed by groups like Anne
toughie how likely is it that our
country will be thrown at the Civil War
sometime in the future or at least an
even worse state of violence all right
we're starting with the Civil War
question ok I well it's interesting
because this this topic has come up
lately it came up at dinner last night
with a few of us is America veering
toward Civil War I I don't think we're
veering towards civil war but I do think
we're veering towards a place where the
way we communicate is breaking down in a
very dangerous way that's why for the
last couple of years what I've tried to
do is explain to people that liberalism
classical liberalism the rights of the
individual so many of the things that
Steve was talking about they have
virtually nothing to do with the modern
left anymore and I was a progressive so
I understand this world I was on The
Young Turks you can do you know I I get
it and what I've tried to do is is
explain to people that if you really
care about the individual if you really
care about logic and reason and
live-and-let-live which is a liberal
principle it's thought of as a
libertarian principle or it's thought of
as some sort of principle of the right
but it really is a liberal principle so
I don't think we're veering toward civil
war but I think we do have massive
problems when when in Berkeley the
police don't arrest these antiva guys
they dressed like Kobra soldiers you
they're the bad guys I mean everyone
should know that and and they should be
arrested we have to we have to have laws
that we uphold but I don't think we're
bearing towards the Civil War I think
also you know look people are much worse
online than they are in real life and
the things that we see all of us are
worse online that we are in real life
right and and you can that's why it's so
important to talk to people it's why I
do what I do for a living I mean if you
get someone across from you and you
disagree with them it's a lot harder to
say horrible things to them right there
then
is online so I think challenging people
that you know in your family and
creating a YouTube channel or whatever
you can do to just keep pushing people
to go alright well we live in a great
pluralistic society and we don't want to
give that up so I don't think we're
weird towards a civil war yet I agree
with that let me try to say something
positive here I think that the the bad
people like anti-shah but all but it's
really I think it's it's not really Anti
Fog
strictly speaking it's it's it's the bad
call it ideologues or people who believe
really bad ideas I still think they're a
vocal minority there's still a minority
of people I don't think most people on
college campuses agree that we should
shut down other people the issue that
we're facing is or the question we all
have to grapple with is are we going to
allow them to to get away with it are we
going to allow this vocal minority to
sort of set a standard for the whole
country are we going to store are we
going to stand up to them and and on all
the free speech events we've had I've
been delighted to see how many students
come out and it's usually filled with
students who really care about grappling
with ideas but but what they need to do
is they be they have to be willing to
stand up they have to be willing to say
I disagree with this they have to be
willing to say this idea that you are no
more than your race sex etc etc is utter
nonsense we're all individuals I'm not
part of your tribe I'm a thinking being
don't purport to speak for me I will
speak for myself and I goddamnit have a
right to speak for myself so that's I
mean that is what people have to have
okay thank you like to echo my companion
statements about thanking each of you
for the amazing work you guys do you
guys are definitely an inspiration to
myself and many other people so thank
you for that now my question is and you
guys brought up a little bit there at
the end but what are libel and slander
laws and what do you think if anything
should be done about them especially
contra Trump was last part especially
what contra Trump oh okay well I think
we we all basically I think agree I I
believe in libel laws I have no problem
with what happened Hulk Hogan taking
down Gawker I was for it when he beat
Iron Sheik in WrestleMania 4 and I was
for it really when he took down Gawker
and we have a right to privacy that is a
guaranteed right that we have in the
Bill of Rights and you you have a right
not to be libeled or slandered now I
think those laws have to be extremely
extremely carefully combed through to
make sure there isn't a chilling effect
on free speech but as a general rule for
them I have no problem with what
happened with Gawker we can't just live
under the threat of constantly being
destroyed especially in a time when
everything that you you do you put out
there you can't just be worried
constantly that somebody can just come
and destroy your reputation and your
family and everything else yeah exactly
and well just an association in fact in
Europe originally hate speech nor as
they were in fact semi light levels
meaning that if you said that Jews are
drinking the blood of Christian children
children you could be taken to court and
have to prove it and if you couldn't
prove it you would be convicted today in
Europe you can say things that are
literally true and
he convicted a racist which i think is
outrageous
speaking about truth so yeah but yeah
libel was in my view er proper it's a
big complicated topic the way I think
about it is you have a right to the
value that you have created in your own
reputation or if you think about it from
the standpoint of a company in your
brand now it's again it's a complicated
issue but you can take an example of
what happened to Johnson Johnson in the
1980s when somebody poisoned tylenol and
think about the damage that was done to
Johnson Johnson it took them years to
regain their reputation imagine if
somebody now said you know across the
internet I've poisoned you know tylenol
imagine how quickly the stock would
plummet nobody would buy it anymore
there's real damage there so the
ultimate issue is if you lie in a way
that damages a value that somebody else
has created and in this case its
reputation you can think of it almost
like an intellectual property right you
can be sued for that but we have to set
the right standards legal standards and
the right defense doesn't mean that
there's no consequence yeah yeah but I
but but but the problem with libel laws
usually in less democratic and free
countries in in in Russia for instance
politicians will take your onus to court
for libel when they criticize you know
what they're doing as politicians of
course that should not be allowed and
that's why we need a very narrowly
defined yep labelling okay
thank you I have a comment and a
question but first thing I would like to
say is that I think the publishing of
that you'd mentioned talked on this a
little bit at the beginning I think the
publishing of the Mohammed cartoons is
is less the heroic thing then what
followed and what you how you reacted in
the storm that you didn't back down that
you stood up for the conclusions of your
reasoning mind and that you're still
doing that now
and for all of you so that's my comment
one of my favorite iron rant quotes is
that the smallest minority on earth is
the individual and that those who will
not defend individual rights cannot be
considered defenders of minorities I
think that's sometimes interpreted to be
about minorities specifically whereas I
think that's the secondary piece of that
and what it's really about is individual
rights I think often when we talk about
free speech we talk around individual
rights and I wonder what your thoughts
are Joel right bliss Italy I mean
visa vie free speech yeah addressing
individual rights explicitly when it
comes to free speech instead of talking
around it what are your thoughts on that
I think I agree that the most important
minority in any society is individual
and it is individual rights that needs
protection not groups and I think you
know when it comes to this issue it is
very important because if you for
instance take the Muslim community
people who are talking about Muslims as
a group and not as individuals they
provide a - to the oppressors within
that group to say you know women gays
atheists all kinds of people that they
do not have a right to exercise the
individual rights within that group
because there are other norms and and
end rules so so so the protection of
individual rights in this context is
also a protection of the right to
dissent within a within a group
and that's I mean that's crucial for for
the fight for freedom and it's crucial
for the kind of process that that a lot
of Muslim communities have to go through
for instance Sweden that is close to
where I live in Denmark there is a
ghetto in in Rosengarten in Malmo and
and some years ago the Ministry of
immigration in Sweden they did an
investigation on this ghetto area and
there were women living there who said
that they felt that they had less
individual rights living in Sweden than
they enjoyed in Beirut in Lebanon
because there was a religious police who
were telling them that they had to cover
themselves that that girls and boys were
not allowed to use the same playground
and so on and so forth and and that is
exactly because you have these
communities and they believe that they
have a right to enforce their own
standards on on everybody without
protecting individual rights yeah I
agree completely that this is an issue
of individual rights we definitely have
to defend it as an issue of individual
rights that's absolutely crucial but I
would also say that you have to
understand that the whole point of
individual rights is to protect our
right to live and thrive and pursue
happiness so I would echo the words of
the Declaration of Independence this is
a positive value proposition it's not
enough just to say I want to be left
alone
I mean it's true strictly speaking as a
legal matter but if you really want
people to get behind this you've got to
teach them that this is a value this is
about living a good life it's not just
about the right to say any damn thing
you want although that is your right so
yeah I agree wholeheartedly that rights
have to be part of it but we have to
convince people that rights are good
thanks so much I really enjoyed the talk
I would have titled that the free speech
trifecta but so my question is you
discussed how debating ideas with others
is necessary for the
development of actualizing our own views
however in high school there's
practically no debating I never really
debated too many ideas in high school do
you think that the lack of debate
education in high school has affected
college students paradigms on free
speech and if so how yeah well it's a
great question and it's it's not just
high school I mean it's college it's
it's everywhere right now I mean it's in
our public discourse it's in cable news
I mean these these aren't debates about
ideas these are usually shouting matches
and I get a tremendous amount of email
from from kids in high school and in
college who are saying that they've
tried to challenge professors and have
been in effect silence sometimes I think
one of the events that we did there were
there was a kid there who was talking
about this whole issue with gender
pronouns and and he was sort of taking
the Jordan Peterson approach which is
that he's wants to be respectful of
trans people but he doesn't want anyone
telling him what pronoun to use he's not
going to go out of his way to offend
anybody you got to use they right or
they or my facebook page I have a public
Facebook page you literally can choose
it I mean that seems offensive to me but
all right but but that this idea of of
not being allowed to debate these things
it's one I mean imagine you're a high
school kid and you want to debate your
teacher well that's tough now you got to
debate the mob on social media too and
everything else so those are the again
it goes to the individual these are the
people that we have to strengthen give
them the tools to to be able to debate
so when they're when they're doing these
things with safe spaces and trigger
warnings they're they're quite literally
stealing the tools that you need to live
in life in in real life you're going to
hear some things you're we're guaranteed
rights not not the ability to not be
offended these are the most important
things you can have in your toolbox so
that you can go forward and live like a
functioning person and be able to use
all your faculty to do whatever you want
in this world and they can take that
from you so that's why it's that's why I
focus so much on the college stuff it's
like you're taking it from the people
that need it the most
and by the way it's just starting there
it'll come for the rest of us yeah I
think the issue though we shouldn't
think of it strictly as you know we need
more debate
and that's not necessarily to disagree
with you guys it's I think I mean
there's education is a mess for a lot of
reasons it's a huge subject we could
spend many hours talking about but
ultimately the purpose of education is
to teach somebody how to think and then
the knowledge they need to live a good
life and that's not being done at any
level of education so it I don't think
of it as we need more debate we need
more good education that teaches
students how to think in critical
thinking especially so but you know if I
were to just enact a halfway measure I
would I would try to you know create
more diversity of ideas and more
debating in schools but I look at that
as a step toward ultimately good
education that teaches people how to
think I'll just toss in one little
technique that I've learned which is
that if you are not a racist and you are
not a homophobe and you are not a bigot
or whatever it is then these words
should have no power over you and the
second you you're the one that gives
them power if they call you these things
I was at Portland State University with
christina hoff sommers they said that
she was a misogynist and that I was
against the gay community I married a
dude I mean that's pretty Pro gay you
know what I mean but that's that's not
even enough for them yeah thank you for
the record I'm not even gay I was just
trying to prove a point with these
people
just using their nonsense against them
but I just wanted to say one thing I say
I think I mean I agree with what Steve
says but I think there is an important
psychological factor here and that is
when when you are confronted with things
that you don't like or with things that
you disagree with it makes you feel
uncomfortable and and I think it's it's
very important that we in school or at
home teach our kids to to to be in
situations that make them feel
uncomfortable and and that's part of the
country culture we are having now that
that parents believe that that their
kids should only feel good and it's not
part of life you know to expose them to
to unpleasant situations without being
you know a masochist but but it's it's
part of growing up that sometimes there
are things that you you don't like to
talk about or it makes you feel not good
but that's important to cultivate this
culture of freedom and tolerance even
though you don't like the word that's I
kind of make my kids feel uncomfortable
constantly yeah probably watching my
town oh yeah absolutely
good evening this question might be
meant principally for mr. Simpson um you
made a point during this session one
that I might be inclined to agree with
you said that public universities could
possibly represent a threat to free
speech because they they could open the
door for government to regulate what we
know and correspondingly what we think
about and say but many of us myself
included couldn't entertain the notion
of paying private school tuition so my
question is this which do you think
poses more of a threat the possibility
that many of us might miss out on being
educated or the three
that government might use university to
manipulate what we think I don't think
that those two things are you know
there's no contradiction there but but
this is a bigger issue about the nature
of market economy and what you would get
if people were actually free to you know
spend their money as they wish and
invest in what they wish I I mean look
obviously there's a huge demand for
education the idea that the government
needs to provide it I think is crazy
it's wrong it's I mean we've had over a
century of it it's Anna Bennett abysmal
failure at the primary level and it
we're seeing the consequences of it at
the the level of higher education but
there's all sorts of market distortions
there so yeah private education is you
know it's it's exorbitantly expensive
part of the reason is that government
has gotten involved in the provision of
education and bid prices up by pumping
gigantic amounts of money into into the
market but that's a more of an economic
phenomenon in a in a really you know
free-market economy i I just I'm
positive there's be no question that
tons of people would provide all kinds
of awesome educational opportunities and
that people would be able to choose
different educational opportunities so I
don't see that really as a you know as a
fundamental threat or there's any
contradiction here thank you
I apply the question of free speech to
radical Islamic preachers like Anjem
Choudary and people like that who are
calling for the downfall of the West and
sometimes directly inciting violence
should they be silenced or should they
be free to say what they feel well I
would say that on the on a direct call
to violence then then there's a legal
issue there I mean you can you there is
no such thing as hate speech Desai you
know I don't know if you saw a governor
Howard Dean couple weeks ago talking
about hate speech and saying that was
illegal and and this is just simply not
true I've invited him on my show he has
not responded but hate speech doesn't
exist a direct call to violence is a
criminal act and then you can call the
authorities
and then they can take action on that as
for what's happening in
England I mean it seems to me that you
have to Fleming maybe I think you're
going to agree with me here but feel
free not to I mean it seems to me you
have to let these people speak yeah it's
vile what they're talking about and I
mean forgetting what they're talking
about that they want to do with with
other minorities religious minorities
and gay people and women and all of
those things they are trying to use the
systems of tolerance that we have in the
West to destroy the West I mean that's
what the you know the difference between
an Islamist and a jihadist who's using
violence an Islamist is trying to use
the systems we have against us I don't
know that stopping them from speaking is
is the right way to to stop their
ideology I'm a firm believer that you
let those ideas out there and you have
to beat them with better ideas but that
one is as close to a place where I could
possibly be convinced of something else
I don't think so at the moment but what
about using our own systems against us
which is so obviously what they're I
mean that's that's what the Communists
did during the Cold War and we managed
pretty well in Denmark we had a
communist party was they were sitting in
Parliament they had their own newspapers
they had their own schools they had
their own unions they had their own
political festivals and they they wanted
to destroy democracy and and put in a
government that was loyal to Moscow and
and I think we did pretty well today we
are we are going in exactly the opposite
direction I mean in Denmark the Nazi
Party was also not paint and it isn't
so so I think we have been pretty good
at fighting totalitarian ideas in
democracy by not banning them but will
with the radical Islam we are doing that
and I think antium Chowdhury it's it's
it's a borderline question but in
general I don't think that you should
prosecute people because they call for
you know is that the establishment of a
Caliphate even when they say that that
unbelievers have to be killed I don't
think that should be a criminal offence
because it means that you should ban the
Quran in that that is a verse from the
Quran so so so I mean I I think the the
right way is to and I would like to I
would like to know if they are living
people among me among among in in the
society where I live who supports these
kind of ideas I would like to know and I
and I that would not be possible if they
are not allowed to speak their mind as
long as they do not incite violence
directly we last year in Denmark we
passed a law criminalizing the condoning
of polygamy in a religious setting which
was specifically targeting Imams which
means if if I was an elected member of
parliament and if I said that in
Parliament I would not be prosecuted but
if I said it in a mosque I would be
prosecuted that's discrimination
and I I think it comes back to this lack
of our ability to manage diversity of
opinions that the Communists and the
Nazis they also they also support on
democratic
means but they they they have more or
less the same social values as we do at
least the communist not announcer's
maybe but you know they drink beer they
go to the movies they listen to rock
music and so on and so forth but but but
but Muslims they they have different
social norms and I think that's that's
that's a huge challenge and it's
write-ins a lot of people and therefore
they think that we have to clamp down on
one all kinds of things by the way the
reason that's so so interesting and so
complex is that you may have seen they
did a documentary I think it was on the
BBC about radical Islam and two of the
killers from London just a couple weeks
ago were in it so it wasn't that these
guys were hiding they were talking about
what they were going to do so in a way
that that works against our defense of
free speech they're using speech to tell
us what they're going to do but you can
so I think the way I would put the
positive point is our systems can't be
used against us if we understand and
implement our systems correctly and
there's a lot of mistakes that I think
our government is making in England too
so in that example I think the police
should have followed those guys and
investigated what they were doing in the
current context people who are talking
about the fact that you know they want
to destroy society they want to kill
people on the basis of any ideology on
that there there's a concept of law
called probable cause and if you're
going around saying I actually want to
kill people and I think other people
should kill people and being vague
enough that that it wouldn't be direct
incitement you know the police should
pursue you and pay attention to you and
decide whether you are the way I would
put it is a criminal gang or conspiring
with other people to destroy or violate
the rights of other people it's it can
get complicated but I mean the basic way
to think about this is that you know you
have the right to speak and advocate
even crazy ideas you don't have the
right to threaten people to incite
violence or to conspire to commit crimes
if you're if the police find that you're
part of a group whose ultimate goal is
to destroy our government or
bomb people or kill people I would think
of it and I think an easier way to think
about it is it's like the Mafia we know
what the Mafia is right it's not now it
may be hard to find out who's a member
of the Mafia but if the guys at the you
know the Italian social club are making
a big deal about how they're going to
rob a bank sometime you don't just say
oh there's nothing we can do because
it's speech now you and you know sorry
about the offends Italians or anything
like you know you tell you my social
club yeah well you know I'm what you
think this is yeah okay I grew up in New
Jersey but the point is that is that you
don't have to governments don't have to
stand for groups that are effectively
criminal conspiracies and just sit idly
by and say we have we can't do anything
about them I actually think during the
Cold War
if I'm correct about this you can
correct me if I'm wrong but as I
understand the American Communist Party
was directly working with the Soviet
Union they should have been investigated
arrested and and and you know and and
prevented from essentially being an ally
or a you know helping aiding and
abetting an enemy of this country that's
not a violation of free speech that's
just basic criminal law so if we if we
thought of it this way and we really
understood wait a minute we can go after
people who are planning to you know
overthrow the government or destroy
people's lives or blow up buildings and
we thought of them as a criminal gang
rather than you know just ideological
emotive it isn't matter why their what
their motivate motivated by theft
destruction ideology it doesn't matter
if you fit the you know the the terms of
a crime or or you're committing a crime
and there there are a number of
different potential crimes that apply
here you're a criminal
in fact the communist part of the USO
was banned legally but it was never
executed in praxis meaning IIIi think
there was a court decision 1952 but but
somehow it was allowed to yeah to exist
more or less openly okay
my question is for mr. Rose had you
known this cope of terrorism and crime
that resulted from publishing the
Mohammed cartoons before publishing them
would you had still published them and
what would be your reasoning first time
I get that question no I didn't know
and the people who today say that I
should have known that it was some kind
of automatic reaction as if you push a
button they are just not honest in in
the fall of 2005 before all hell broke
loose in the Middle East a very
prominent Danish expert on Islam said
after the publication of the cartoons
that this is never going to be a big
international issue is too small and and
the fact of the matter is that cartoons
of the Prophet Mohammed have been
published before without triggering
triggering these kind of of the
reactions you know if I say that in in
light of the violence that is that
erupted that I wouldn't do it I think I
would send a very bad signal to to all
kind of violent people basically telling
them that if you threaten intimidate and
using our violence I will do exactly as
you please
on the other hand of course I'm not I'm
not suicidal
you know it's as I said to Dave it's not
nice to receive death threats in the
email but and and I I mean I don't think
that you should if if you know how
people will react in advance
you should used to think about the
consequences of what you say but I just
think here I I think the the the problem
was that that when the violence erupted
I was I became the scapegoat and and it
was as if a lot of people in the West
thought that Muslims belong to a
different species that they don't have a
mind and brain to reason and make a
decision about how they're going to
react as if it's just you know they're
like animals or like small children
they're not able to make a decision for
themselves about how to react to an
offensive cartoon and therefore I was
the perpetrator and they not the people
who committed the actual violence and I
think that was the problem and and there
was a original sin I think that was a
phrase Gregg Lou Khanna from fire used
at some point if if most newspapers in
the West back then had republish the
cartoons not not as an act of support
because publication does not mean
endorsement to a publisher you can still
write in editorial saying you know we
disagree with the decision to publish
but they are newsworthy and people have
to make our decision for themselves what
they think about these cartoons and you
are not taking your readers seriously if
you if you believe that you can only
show them things that they that they
like
and I and I think I think that the New
York Times they made a huge mistake it
reads on the top of the New York Times
all the news that fit to print and
February 1st 2006 the cartoons they they
were news item number one in the world
but they they decided not to publish
them as most of the big American
newspapers did and I think that was that
was a real mistake if everybody had
published then as you know basically
saying this is this is the right thing
to do we may not agree with the content
of the continuance but it's important to
a population because they are in the
news then you would have we we might
have been in a different place now
because today nobody not even in Europe
published cartoons of the Prophet
Mohammed
not the you newspaper where I used to
work at you don't suppose they don't do
it anymore
there's only newspaper one newspaper in
Europe that did this
Charlie Abdul and and and they were
killed
yeah and as someone saying they don't do
it anymore they've announced that they
won't talk about right but the editor in
chief in fact that was an interview with
dash D Stan in in Germany and the editor
in chief said afterwards that he had
been misquoted and that they would still
do it if they find it relevant I don't
know if that's true or not but but he in
fact corrected the crowd but it's also
true that
sinop female cartoon is the Charlie
Hebdo she left because she thought that
they had gone soft on on Islam but I
mean I I you know I will not criticize
Charlie Hebdo I mean 12 people were
killed
and so so I I think it's fair for them
to say you know we've done our part of
the struggle now other people have to
take over even though I think it's very
humiliating it's very very humiliating
for anyone as a partner as a journalist
to to cave in to these kinds of threats
and it it it works the other way I mean
if you if if you show people that
intimidation works why should they stop
yeah yeah and and what Fleming's talking
out there is I love the phrase the soft
bigotry of low expectations because
that's that's exactly what you're
talking about you're saying that these
people don't have the capacity to deal
with the cartoon I mean you know there's
a Broadway show The Book of Mormon guess
what there is not going to be the book
of the 'quran and it would not be a hero
it would not be this amazing thing to
everyone on the Left when when the Pope
that remember a couple years ago in in
New York City was it at the Met they had
the Pope drawn in in feces that was on
the front page of the New York Times
there's another image that they would
not show so this is that you're saying
okay we can offend certain people
because we know they behave a certain
way but this other group we're not even
going to give them the chance and in a
bizarre way that's actual bigotry could
you comment on the relationship between
profanity censorship and hate speech
laws do they spring from the same source
provider you mean like the FCC
oh yes basically although it's been in
our culture for eons it seems I mean
even our parents sensory us and of
course the media is a censored from by
the FCC yes well I would say you could
say any [ __ ] thing you want
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] for the
other two the george carlin loose yeah
what are the other two yeah [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
[ __ ] tits you left out tits I
know this is the part of the show
that'll get clipped and shared around so
wait what was it come on I got a 500
people it'd piss [ __ ] now I
think they're just heckling us one more
time the guy in the hat's got it go good
night everybody
right no just kidding okay it sounds
like poetry almost it is poetry yeah I
feel like we answered that question well
one one point though it's not censorship
for your parents not to tell you not to
say that that's not censorship and it's
wrong to think that that is censorship
that's a so what the FCC did was
definitely censorship but but saying I'm
you know I'm not going to say certain
words in certain contexts that's not
censorship that's often good judgment
often bad judgment but we have to decide
it in the context of having said that I
swear in front of my kids all the damn
time but anyway my question concerns the
concept of self-censorship at the outset
of the discussion they've made a I
believes a disparaging comment but
someone who said I'm not going to shave
share this image from your page because
someone might unfriend me on Facebook my
question concerns people with more
serious fears justifiable fears of
violence would you would you call that
self-censorship or something else and
are you at all critical I'm thinking of
for example in certain Muslim countries
if you post on Facebook there is no god
someone will kill you the government
will not protect you or the college
administrator who says you know it would
be good to book that person but my
campus will be trashed and my people
will be attacked
well speech has consequences so if you
are in if you're in a country that you
know they're gonna come get you or
arrest you or whatever it is or your
neighbors are going to turn on you
that's not good but it is it is a
reality I don't judge those people for
that
I mean look look at Fleming who lived in
a West Lidz still you know in a western
country did something by that by every
standard is okay to do in a western
country and and the consequences he has
to deal with it if I right now was just
to literally quote Bill Maher from two
weeks ago
just quote him that's it there would be
consequences to me so I don't you know
everybody I get a ton of email about
this people are afraid to say what they
think that's that's the issue right now
that's what I believe to be the biggest
issue nothing that we were going to say
up here we did not censor ourselves in
any way so that you hid you we suddenly
hit our secretly racist or bigoted views
but that doesn't mean we're just going
to come up here and say every crazy
thing that we can possibly do because we
know there are repercussions I had a
woman on my show that from Iraq some of
you may have seen this about two years
ago she was an atheist in Iraq I when
she wanted to do my show I said you
don't have to show your face if you
don't want to she wanted to do it she
said if I don't do it then no one's
going to ever do it she ended up getting
all sorts of death threats we had to
take the video away I found out just
yesterday that she's been admitted to
the United States
so sometimes you have to be brave you
have to be brave but I don't but I don't
begrudge or judge the people that can't
find the courage to do it it's it's not
fun I have cameras outside of my house
and I'd prefer not to but here we are oh
yeah I I I mean you asked about a
definition of self-censorship
and as I said I commissioned those
cartoons as part of a debate about
self-censorship and and many people have
said to me you know we need
self-censorship in order to be able to
live together because if everybody
speaks that what they what's on their
mind all the time we would not be able
to live together and I think that's a
delusion of the concept of
self-censorship to me self-censorship
means that there are things that I would
like to say but I I refrain from saying
them because I'm afraid what might
happen to me if I say it and I think
that's different from etiquette and it's
different from good manners and in
certain social norms and I agree with
with Dave you cannot you cannot condemn
people for you know refraining from
saying things that will cause violence
against them but but but you also have
to remember that there are consequences
if everybody keeps Island and a whole
society start internalizing certain
norms because there are things that
because the government has intimidated
the public space so so and we also have
to remember that that that the struggle
for free speech and the struggle against
censorship is not a free right there are
people earlier in history who really
paid with their lives for our rights big
are mine today
but I'm but I'm not calling and people
too sacrificing themselves that's you
know everybody has to make a decision
for himself but but the self-censorship
does have consequences yeah I also think
it's important to say the you know one
one one one interesting thing about the
cartoons and violence because a lot of
people usually say you know the cartoons
that cause violence in the Middle East
no start the cartoons that cause
violence people made decisions to commit
violence and and and and the funny thing
here is that all the violence in fact
took place in countries without freedom
of expression where it was a criminal
offence to publish these kind of
cartoons while in countries will free
speech where it was not a criminal
offence to publish these kind of
cartoons there was no violence at the
time and there is still far less
violence than they used to be which is
an indication of the fact that if you
cultivate a culture of freedom of
expression it's easier to manage these
kind of disagreements and anger without
resorting to violence and and and and
blasphemy laws in fact Denmark just got
rid of its blasphemy law and I think you
signed the petition and Iran deal as
well just two weeks ago which is great
but but the Danish government that
wanted to keep it on the books used the
argumentation that that was a way to
make society more safe so if you
criminalize certain kinds of speech then
people will not say it and you will not
offend people's religious sensibilities
and then they will not commit violence
but it turns out that there is a very
close correlation between blasphemy laws
and terrorism and lack of freedom of
expression if you look at Indonesia
Pakistan and Nigeria you have seen an
escalation in the application
of blasphemy laws by the governments and
in escalation in terrorist violence by
groups like al-qaeda Boko Haram in
Nigeria and a leading terrorist group
Muslim terrorist group in Indonesia so I
would I would I would make the argument
that blasphemy laws in fact incite
violence because the government
basically tells society that it's okay
to use violence against blasphemers
because this is a very very serious
crime in Pakistan you have you have the
death penalty for blasphemy which which
means that you will get the same the
same sentence if you publish cartoons of
The Moth the Prophet Mohammed or publish
and novel like The Satanic Verses by
Simon Lucia roasting or kill 500 people
in a terrorist attack it's it's a
similar similar criminal offense and
that's why people take the law into
their own hands and they kill
blasphemers in prisons and and in
villages and and so on and so forth
I think it makes sense that you would
see that correlation I haven't studied
it but you know because what blasphemy
laws do if you put them on the books it
just emboldened the irrational violent
people who want to shut down thought and
ultimately they want to enslave people
anytime you appease evil you get more of
it related to this free speech issue how
do you differentiate between the
political violence of college protesters
today and organizations like by any
means necessary
and the violence conducted by Americans
during the Revolutionary War that's
quite a jump there
well as in terms of using violence to
achieve political ends as opposed to
ideas and reason so the founders were
right to oppose tyranny they had a good
argument against it they had you know
they were fighting for freedom and so
they were morally correct - they were
opposing tyranny those who are using
violence they are not up really they're
not opposing tyranny certainly not and
they live in a rule of law society in
which there are all kinds of ways you
can deal with laws and government
actions and other people that you
disagree with far short of violence it's
crazy to resort to violence
in a country like this which is
basically free and basically protects
your rights it's not perfect by any
means but you have to make a distinction
I mean you know the the founders were
willing to openly rebel against their
government and then you have to judge
why any whether any group that is that
resorts to rebellion is doing so for
proper moral reasons or horrible evil
reasons so there's just there's
absolutely no grounds for resorting to
violence in this country today
none whatsoever it's crazy and it's and
it will promote the very tyranny that
they pretend to be against they're not
against tyranny they're in favor of
tyranny because in effect they're in
favor of a kind of anarchism and a and a
lawlessness and that always leads to
tyranny so that's how you have to gensou
but I mean I don't think the two things
are really commensurate but you can't
hold it as anybody who is opposing
something on the basis of political
ideas and willing to resort to violence
is somehow kulit they're not you have to
judge them some of them are good and
appropriate the founders some of them
are horrible and evil French Revolution
Communist revolution Maoist revolution
you know all of the other total
revolutions that led to totalitarianism
and the people who are resorting to
violence today are crazy there's no
justification for whatsoever and I would
say even in cases where there is a
justification for using violence if
you're living in a totalitarian
dictatorship its issues and
a very effective way of a fighting gene
sharp I think it says Howard has studied
these you know secessionist movements
and people fighting for freedom
independence and so on and so forth and
it turns out that that the nonviolent
struggle in fact is far more effective
and and and and and the movements that
are able to to stay within the limits of
nonviolent struggles are quite often
more effective and and it's also the
thing that if you go down the road of
violence it's very difficult to stop and
and and usually it has very tragic
consequences for for even you know
people who you would say they have a
legitimate right to choose violence to
to fight for for their rights
how can an individual promote freedom of
speech on a college campus without
ending communications and conversations
with peers by alienating them I mean
this is the toughest one for you guys
I'm actually really impressed how many
young people there are here it that's
the toughest one you are gonna I when I
had sort of my political awakening over
the last couple of years I've lost a ton
of friends I've gained new ones but the
so-called tolerant side doesn't seem to
be that tolerant of ideas that they're
not thrilled with and you're going to be
confronted with that constantly you know
if you if you fight for the individual
it will somehow appear in their minds
not in reality but in their minds it
will somehow appear that you're fighting
for other people's oppression or you're
fighting for the the patriarchy or this
just all these nonsensical buzzwords
they come up with and you just have to
be clear that you're not one effective
thing is you got to look your friend in
the eye
am i bigoted what have I done that is
racist do you
I've said something or acted homophobic
or whatever it is I think if you can get
it down to that I just happen to think
something differently politically and
and that's okay
even just in the last couple weeks for
as much of this as I do for a living I
had dinner with some old childhood
friends that I went to elementary school
with and they know my opinions very well
and two of them are very far left
progressives ones that one's a Trump guy
and we were at a restaurant in New York
City and it was getting heated and we
were screaming at her I was screaming I
was being screamed at but there was
there was screaming going on and I just
paused it and I said guys we have been
friends for 30-some odd years it is not
going to end at this table right now so
we and we moved on to talking about
basketball and and and then we started
fighting again because this guy thinks
that Kevin Durant is better than LeBron
which is completely idiotic finals
notwithstanding but but I think that
technique like one of the biggest
problems we have now is that everything
is politicized everything everyone
thinks that every conversation you have
to have should be about politics and
it's somehow a referendum on what you
think about everything and if you don't
say something that implies that you must
think something and all of these crazy
things so I think using reason and logic
and really making it about you I think
is the most effective way to fight it
which I guess is kind of you it's on you
it's on you yeah but I I also think it's
very important to try to clear up
misunderstandings about what free speech
implies because a lot of people today
believe that free speech is just a
cover-up for the right of the powerful
to attack the weak and and and that's a
very important history missing here and
it turns out that all the way through
history that social National all kinds
of movements for political and social
change they have benefited from freedom
of expression and they have insisted on
their right as a weak minority to speak
out against
that's the civil rights movement it's
women movements it's the gay movement
all kinds of of minorities have in fact
benefited from freedom of expression and
and and and and it's it's important for
them for the week to to have freedom of
expression to speak their mind and and
and and these kind of misunderstandings
it's very important to you know to to to
clear these these misunderstandings up
do we have a little flexibility on time
I want to get everybody possible okay
granted that uh all ideas should be
protected under free speech and that bad
ideas should and can best be combatted
by better truer ideas what about speech
that has no idea content whatsoever
things like insults racial slurs and
maybe a picture of the Prophet Mohammed
I don't think it's true that they don't
have any idea content but it is not
ultimately up to government to decide
what has idea content versus what
doesn't it's ultimately up to government
to enforce laws against in my view
against you know the initiation of force
and and that protect rights so the issue
isn't are your ideas good ones where are
they do they qualify as ideas as opposed
to just blabber are they racist are they
you know do they have a lot of substance
or are they hollow that's not ultimately
the question the question is do you you
know you you have the right to speak you
have the right to speak your mind you
have the right pretty much to say
anything you want so long as you don't
violate the rights of others and I mean
that's a it can be a complicated
question of what constitutes a violation
of Rights but it doesn't turn on the
content of the ideas and I think it's
wrong to say that racist speech has no
ideas it's not really true they're bad
ideas but they
our ideas real quickly even the cartoons
if right now we had a piece of paper and
I drew a stick figure and on the bottom
I wrote Moses nobody would care if I
wrote Jesus nobody would care if I wrote
Muhammad you guys would be looking for
the exits so this shows you that it's
not about the thing it's about the idea
behind the thing so you have to just not
give those ID if that doesn't offend you
then don't give someone else's offense
power over your own mind and actually
yeah and I'm rolling here right now I
mean I would say that the come on ha ha
ha I'm gonna step off stage for a more
no but but the most famous of those
cartoons that is of the Prophet Muhammad
with a bomb in his turban is very
specifically expressing an idea it it
says that there are Muslims who are
committing terrorist acts in the name of
the Prophet and and that's an idea yeah
para para but I think one of one of one
of the beautiful things about about the
US First Amendment tradition is that
here you can never criminalize speech
exclusively because of its content I
would love us to have that kind of
principle in in in in Europe you can
talk about the effect of speech but you
cannot say just because of the content
that that something should not be
allowed to be said I find the way I
think that that cartoon is brilliant I
think it's a brilliant example of
political cartoons so called political
cartoons at their height Amin it conveys
precisely everybody knew what that meant
the moment they looked at it yeah and
it's it's the irony is that you know
that there are some Muslims who are
saying you know if if you say we are
violent we are going to kill you
[Music]
all right we're going to try to get to
okay short short questions short
questions short answers here we go the
last couple people what I meant by our
racial slurs insults and I guess a
picture of Prophet Mohammed the common
denominator there it's kind of a
provocation to violence in varying
degrees now I haven't seen these
Mohammed cartoons I don't know I'm sure
they had plenty of idea content behind
them and the extreme of the provocation
to violence it seems like the Prophet
Mohammed thing is kind of just grafted
on to their ideology like it has no no
real significance to their ideas one way
or another it's kind of just this like
categorical like imperative eyelet of
like what they're most certainly going
to get extremely mad at and like whether
like you're aware of this or not
beforehand like it seems to me at best
that this isn't Liz amoral at best to
like and free speech to draw a picture
of Prophet Muhammad all right well you
know in the spirit of brevity how about
we all agree don't kill people over
cartoons can we agree on that we're good
all right all right we do have to move
on a little bit so let's try to get to
the last any of you out more than I
wanted to yeah so we gotta get on here
we gotta get on to nxj thank you yeah hi
so getting back to Steve's comment that
the biggest threat from government just
to free speech nowadays is actually the
failure of government to protect our
rights I was wondering what you feel
about or David view of it any opinion on
the Iranian fatwa against Salman Rushdie
which is they've renewed last year and
whether it's the responsibility of
Western governments to do anything it
takes to resolve that situation well
well certainly against the
fatwa salman rushdie oblong what you are
i am against nabela salman rushdie's
head yes i don't know that the guy I
don't know that our government I suppose
we could use sanctions or pressure I
don't want I wouldn't want to threaten
military action to get a fatwa up on
guys head
I don't know that what our government
can do about that but what we can do for
for Salman is to offer him all of the
protections we have in this country to
come here and spread his great ideas of
which he has many so they also
encouraged violence against American
bookstores right after the book was
published yeah I mean oh look plenty of
countries promote plenty of bad things I
don't think we can totally police the
world I think we should have done
something about it but what exactly it
would have looked like is is open to
question I'm not an expert on military
things but definitely we should have
done something if you look at it think
about it from now Charlie there's a
direct line from the Solomon Rushdie
affair right up to Charlie Hebdo and and
beyond we could have stopped it back
then we didn't that that was appeasing
evil regimes we definitely should have
taken action all right two more here we
go what should one do to challenge hate
speech laws especially in Europe and to
which extent should you personally do
something even if you get into trouble
for it what was the question to what
extent should we challenge hate speech
laws and what's your big issue every
possible extent I mean hate speech laws
I don't think that I'm against them as a
matter of principle but also as a matter
of what's effective to fight hate
whatever that means Europe or the
European Union the reason d'etre of the
European Union is that we somehow
believe that we if we eradicate hate
then eternal peace will erupt
and and it's just a utopia and as it
happens within utopia when you try to
put it into practice its first victim is
freedom and and and it's the same here
I'm against hate speech laws but
unfortunately instead of getting rid of
them more and more European countries
are passing more one more of these laws
and and I think it's you know I think
it's a reaction to the refugee crisis
growing tensions within our societies
but also a way of managing the digital
technology but but hate speech laws they
are bad I mean it's not an effective way
to to fight bigotry it's really not a
very effective way and as a matter of
principle as I said I believe that hate
speech laws they are just an attempt to
enforce one set of social norms it's not
it's in fact they are not intended to
fight hate if if you really wanted to to
fight hate you should criminalize a lot
of things and not only the kind of
things that are the kind of speech that
are being prosecuted
within these hbt lowers they are bad but
they are proliferating and and and just
to your notification that has never been
so much regulation of speech in the
world as we have today but would you
agree that saying outrageous things
actually alleviates these hate speech
laws or makes them just worse in a
response look can I just take it I think
we have to move quickly there the one
thing I would say I don't think saying
outrageous things is going to solve this
we have to defend the freedom to think
and the right to think and recognize how
important that is and the second point I
would make is that you absolutely it
cannot work to force people to think
even what is true all you can do is
destroy people and ultimately destroy
society and enslave it yeah and and and
who is to define what is outrageous
one man's hate speech is another man's
poetry
all right the Big Finish first off I
believe you were the guy who gave us all
seven dirty words correct one more time
one more time for the good people I
can't tell if you're kidding or not
self-censorship right so solution all
right good
in the English lexicon there are very
few words as incendiary lately I think
you have to say it actually because I
can't have one guy yelling no so we're
not going to say words at a free speech
battle so I got to say it I think
several words that you can't say on
television yeah [ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and tits okay
we're all okay everyone's okay all right
in the English lexicon there are very
few words as incendiary as the word
[ __ ] now why is it good evening to
German by oh man
okay why isn't that livestream why is it
that you gentlemen the people in this
room and most people anywhere else
cannot say this word without reproach
thank you
well I mean actually this is exactly the
conversation we were having a dinner
before this and I don't know I don't
know that I can give you an answer
that's going to be satisfying to you I
think it's a it's actually a major
problem that I have no desire to offend
people I have no desire to say a word to
intentionally inflame people but should
every protected group have a word that
we can't say about them or every not
protected minority group or whatever it
is should everyone have a word that the
rest of us can't say it's a real problem
but it's it's a it's not an intellectual
problem I think because I agree with the
premise of your question but it's a it's
a societal problem that this thing has
become so politicized and sort of toxic
that again Bill Maher who has been the
standard bearer of the left I don't
think anyone would say Bill Maher has
been racist in any way has promoted it
you may not like his policies you may
not like his leftist policies that would
be fine
but I don't think anyone's walk around
going Bill Maher's racist and he
basically had to apologize on his own
show and kiss the ring of the IceCube
iced tea iced Arnold Palmer I don't
remember but but you see my point like
you say yeah okay so Steve take it away
so very quickly I would say there are
good reasons that that that word is not
said in bad reasons that it's not said
it depends on the context I'm being but
let's face it it's it's a word with a
really horrifying bad history there all
kinds of reasons what it shouldn't be
said but that's an individual judgment
and I mean there's there's a lot to say
on this topic I think there's there's a
lot to do with you know guilt and and
the entire kind of multicultural
atmosphere that has prevented people
from talking about issues of race but
and and while I don't think and I'll be
controversial to say I don't think Bill
Maher should have apologized for that at
all but that doesn't mean one should
advocate that people say that word it's
it's so there's a lot more to say about
this but you know we have to ultimately
be willing to think about the context in
which words are used and have
conversations and evaluate and
judge the people who who speak alright
thank you
you know Fleming's are professional
because that was an excellent use of
head nodding to get us through the
question thank you guys for for joining
us I hope you found this as as
enlightening as I did I totally enjoyed
this thank you oh come on you can do
better than that give me that
objectiveness thing that the boys
all right thank you guys what a funny